what up space fam golson here from anime
uproar back at it again to discuss the
latest chapter of the one punch man
manga
a lot of you enjoyed my last few one
punch man videos and if you do want to
keep them coming on this channel the
best you could do is smash that like
button and share this video with any
heroes for fun that you know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select
all or you will miss future one punch
man videos while you wait for the next
chapter
and or video to drop feel free to check
out my growing one punch man playlist
where we got videos about the s-class
heroes a-class heroes
dragon and god level monsters blast and
more
link to that playlist in the description
now without further ado
let's jump into it we start with
monstrous psychos
lodging her powerful blast at tatsumaki
and my boy jenos comes in with the
rescue
and not gonna lie tatsumaki's face
looked pretty worried before
genos came to intercept that shot he
launches an epic true spiral
incineration cannon attack
at psychosome attack and you have to
take the time sometimes to appreciate
the names of these attacks
one punch man walks that fine line
between actually being a conventional
shonen
in the sense of having epic tense fights
between cool characters but
also makes fun of all the shonen tropes
at the same time
that way we get the adrenaline-filled
fights but also some golden comedy as
well
it's a win-win in my books and with this
attack incineration canon probably would
have been enough but
jenos throws in true spiral before it
for good measure
and the hilarious part is that the dude
has to at least in the english
translation
say 10 syllables in the heat of battle
while watching his attack
that's twice as many as kamehameha mind
you but let's leave the comedy for now
and get back to the action the two beams
clash like two commandments
it's intense and psycho says that jenos
can't overpower her head on
geno simply screams and manages to split
up psychosis blast
jenos then tells tatsumaki to do it now
and she brings the hostages to safety
we see atomic samurai who had some
hilarious moments in the past chapters
involving a naked puripuri prisoner
and here he suddenly opens his eyes he
turns and putipuri prisoner is there
with his naked body facing him saying
rise and shine
and atomic samurai freaks out probably
not what he expected to wake up to
we see super alloy dark shine and the
huge buff dude is in the fetal position
it seems he was traumatized from his
scuffle with garrow the human monster
even if he doesn't seem to be injured we
also get to see bang
his brother and fubuki tatsumaki's
younger sister
being taken to safety and tatsumaki
can't help but smile
she's overjoyed that they're finally
safe at this point geno seems to have
used up his power but psychos has not
and just launches another blast just
like the first that took
all generals had to stop it things look
really bad at this point
as psycho says that they lost their
shield and are about to meet their doom
she's shocked to see tatsumaki using her
powers to successfully hold back the
blast
and we get some panels with tatsumaki
holding genos which i feel like will
give shippers of them something to work
with
although i'm most interested in the
dynamic between saitama and tatsumaki
myself tatsumaki says that she can
finally fully focus on the fight
she couldn't be serious before because
she was diverting focus
and power to help protect the others the
question was
how much power was that costing her we
get a cool moment where tatsumaki
praises genos
which is rare for this tune that had no
doubt only then do we start to see how
opi tatsumaki seems in relation to this
insanely powered up psychos who as i
explained in the last chapter review
could straight up meet the criteria for
a god level threat because she could
threaten
all of humanity and considering that
what tatsumaki is about to do
is all the more impressive she easily
casts aside the beam
and uses her psychic powers to make
psychos freeze in place
she can't even move a single finger this
is complete overpowering a flex
of epic proportions we see just how
threatening tatsumaki is
and how much she loves her sister when
we see her looking scarier than any
villain we've seen thus far
psychos who remember is the planet
endangering monster here
is sweating buckets right now you do not
threaten tatsumaki's sister
and even fubuki is sweating buckets when
she senses tatsumaki's power
right now we're told that the power up
there is increasing
and bang asks if her physical ability is
limitless
fubuki thinks to herself that
tatsumaki's concentration has improved
and makes it clear that tatsumaki is
planning to finish this right here and
now
i gotta admit i was thinking that
saitama might be the one to come in
with the effortless kill here but now it
seems like tatsumaki is gonna get to
shine
cycles the monster is shocked that
tatsumaki had this much more to give
and calls her a monster and when a
monster calls you a monster
that's pretty epic people watching over
city z think there might be a technical
glitch
but it's actually tatsumaki straight up
warping and twisting the city
imagine the damage that could cause if
tatsumaki was a villain and the fact
that she could deal like this with a
potential threat to all of humanity
means she is definitely a potential god
level threat herself
that is if she ever turned against the
heroes not that that would happen but
it's just fun to think about when power
scaling characters
although we obviously shouldn't take
power scaling too seriously in one punch
man since we were previously told of
psychosis seemingly
limitless and unmeasurable powers but
clearly it didn't take her long to reach
her limits against tatsumaki
and that's part of shonen you gotta hype
up the villain and things
took a complete 180 here since
previously tatsumaki really looked like
she was on the brink of defeat
and now she's definitely the
overpowering force she rings psychos out
along with the city like an old rag
suggesting that the monster absorbed a
lot of power so she's draining her of it
it starts raining blood child emperor
gets protected from debris by
pig god and saitama is still dealing
with the monster underground
telling him he wants his boss to cut it
out since he will wreck his house
obviously though our fellow weak monster
can't really do anything about that
if only he had that much sway over
cycles as saitama thinks and besides
it's not even a monster but tatsumaki
who's causing the damage
and i appreciate how saitama isn't at
all worried about his life but just
about his house
the buried flashy flash starts
complaining about shifting rocks and
finally saitama says there's
no time to be careful and starts
unburying him
with great speed the flashy flash is
great concern
meanwhile the mighty king is having
trouble climbing stairs and he's
exhausted while the child
hostage runs easily ahead of him their
upstairs journey becomes a downstairs
journey
as the building falls tatsumaki is
clearly causing a lot of damage and it
seems to be working
psycho seems finished but it's not over
the last thing tatsumaki says
is she's gotta stop psychos heart
suggesting that psychos can still
regenerate at this point
i'm looking forward to seeing where we
go from here because we've already had
so many twists in this one fight that i
wouldn't be surprised by another
especially since the last thing they
mentioned is that the heart is still
alive
when they could have definitely ended
this chapter on a more definitive note
if it was truly over
and i feel like we need to see more from
saitama 2
in regards to actual fighting we'll see
but one thing is for sure
tatsumaki's power is terrifying we don't
even know its limits since she clearly
wasn't struggling here to overpower
psychos
it wasn't even close when she had her
full concentration and since
psychos had the power to straight up
shave off portions of the earth
i'd say that that could position
tatsumaki in god level territory
at least within the definition of this
series again though
i feel like even a god level threat
could be dealt with by saitama with
relative ease
yet it's still fun to see stronger
opponents and the full power of our top
s-class heroes
by the way if you are interested in
specific s-class heroes you could check
out my recent video about the mysterious
number one hero blast
and everything we know about him so far
link to that in the description
and that is it for this chapter thank
you so much for watching if you want to
keep the one punch man
chapter reviews coming on this channel
the best thing you can do is smash that
like button share this video with any
heroes for fun that you know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select
all or you will miss future one punch
man videos while you wait for the next
chapter
and or video to drop feel free to check
out my growing one punch man playlist
where we got videos about the s-class
heroes
a-class heroes dragon and god level
monsters and much more
link to that playlist in the description
and give me some suggestions for future
video topics
that you are burning up to see i also
want to thank all of you because the
channel has been growing so fast and
it's amazing
we passed 990 000 subscribers and are
actually approaching 1 million
subscribers and it's all thanks to you
guys and i especially want to thank the
patron squad over on patreon and here on
youtube
who help make videos like this one
possible between patreon and the youtube
join function we have well over 100
patrons right now
which is just mind-blowing and amazing
first and foremost i want to thank the
patrons of legend
the ones acknowledged by lord twigo
himself alpha sigma and liam thompson
and
are the one-tier patrons the ones who
stand atop all clans
ingrata the world acquire respect but
they have a jonathan king rathu and they
aura
emperor otaku thomas jones ken mono
admirath
and christopher torley and our pro hero
to your patrons
the one and only gilgamesh who's the
current most donated overall champion of
the world
nothing but a fan kings eldris anatoly
kazotsky angel cruz
cricket xp joe stanton very gucci alicia
actor
hirokami and water bonnie parks jason
wilson florian
joe and garcia steelers mcshamus jessica
kayla fawn deadly saints stern hawkins
and high school dxd73
thank you all so much if you enjoy our
work you can support more of it by going
over to patreon.com
anime upload and becoming a patron today
for as well as one dollar if you do so
you'll get your name featured in future
videos alongside these amazing people
right here
and you'll even get access to our
private patronly discord where we talk
about anime life and of course
thank memes so check out patreon.com
anime upload link in the description if
you're interested
you can also join the youtube channel by
clicking that blue join button next to
the subscribe button that you've
hopefully already destroyed
so yeah you can support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support us you can get the
same
great benefits thanks again and until
next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you